tu veux écrire un mot sur chacun c'est
interdit à l'acor va très bien et je
suis très heureux tu sois avec nous tu
va réagir surtout avec marouane et je
sens que l'émission va être folle tu es
content d'être avec nous ça faisait
oui exactement dix ans mais les voir
faire disons que j'ai pas vu ça fait
disons que c'est pas vu je sais on a vu
les deux audi zigotos way stomie et pacy
ouais mais quoi je n'avais pas vu
j'aimerais que tu m'aimais plus t'es
dingue parce que c'est vrai qu'on va
prendre on était très potes tous les
deux oui franchement c'est vrai très
très potes et je peux vous dire on se
voyait à la bibliothèque
je te rappelle
c'est vrai beaucoup fait de lecture
ensemble ouais ouais on a appris
beaucoup de choses sur la vie oui oui
calme toi quand même allez continuer par
fairway
si tu arrives
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je le trouve tu qui fait george michael
sur wii depuis wam
webb a laissé parler de moi wake me up
before you go
[Musique]
et je mesure il faut laisser une caméra
sur les deux demi-finales du defender de
la gueule non pas du tout elle est
exceptionnelle les deux à côté certes
c'est un des noms mais l'inconnue sera
pourquoi vous voulez répondre à faut
répondre à des enjeux fait il va nous
guérir tout le ballon merci à être
enlevé le truc c'est une barrette
il ya une barrette way offrir des
muscles barre et d'hélium
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me dois de l'argent et n'a jamais été
sur tf1 ça d'un coup qu'un jeans et
caucus libéral je les attends chez toi
tu es plutôt encore alors c'est normal
j'allais boire un coup mais je le suis
fan du gardon jours vous allez jouer
avec nos barrois d'aller jouer avec nous
dont bien sûr le salon bruno oui ça va
être des commencements célibataires
comme toujours à terre pas dire
complètement
oui j'ai pas du tout de l'état ni
c'est-à-dire n'a pas de petite amie ans
non non non je suis célibataire
célibataire oui bien sûr célibataire est
avec toi
pour l'instant la branche moi au moins
je ne sais pas à ton genre c'est ça
bruno non c'est géraldine giraud
sinon il est intelligent mais voilà ces
tortures et quoi elle dit c'est ton
style oui
se mettre au soleil c'est quand même
fort allez on va jouer tout de suite
c'est le jeu de baston regarde je ne va
pas le montre ouais et bientôt
[Applaudissements]
ça s'accélère
merci qui se permettent de vendre des
trucs et ou s'il n'est pas mon chéri que
tu fais je suis fait l'oeuf du pardon
ils seront acquises au titre
conférence débat les roulants
conducteurs
ça bloque ou du calais ce qu'il veut
marois a une idée ouais attend encore je
veux lui écrire un truc où elle a
commencé à travailler un texte avec elle
sur un sur chacun de vous attirer c'est
en fait un raid un truc sur 13eme
arrondissement
j'ai lu un article où il est interdit de
recenser les communautés et je lui
parlais ce que ça te dirait de
travailler avec moi sur ce sujet
d'accords battu voilà bien fait de venir
ouais tu veux créer un mot sur chacun
c'est interdit à l'acor m
[Rires]
[Musique]